How do we raise self-reliant kids
who have initiative, who are resilient,
and who could be problem solvers?
Kids who have the skills and the courage
to step outside of their comfort zone
and take advantage
of what life has to offer.
I'm a mom to these three boys.
And if you're a parent like me,
you've probably asked yourself
those very same questions.
And while I'm sure
that every caring parent
wants those same things
for their children,
I think we're going about it
the wrong way.
We want our kids
to be happy and successful.
So our instinct is to shield them
from hurt and disappointment.
We worry about their self-esteem,
so we praise them for everything.
We are concerned about whether
or not they fit in,
so we indulge them.
And we don't want them to fail,
so we step in and take over.
And we do all of this in an attempt
to curate a perfect life for them.
But what we're really doing
is raising kids
who are afraid to take risks
because they fear failure;
kids who lack the confidence
in their ability to figure things out;
and then young people who are afraid
to launch into adulthood.
More young adults are living at home
and for longer stretches.
And this was occurring
even before the pandemic.
A Pew Research study found
that 52 percent of young adults
are living at home,
which is the highest percentage
since the Great Depression.
And what we're finding
is that young adults are stuck
between adolescence and adulthood.
And that's the generation
of people that we're raising.
And in fact,
we hear this in the language
that young adults even use
when they have to make
responsible adult decisions.
There's a term for it.
Who knows what that is?
Adulting, yes.
The practice of behaving
in a characteristic
of a responsible adult.
So I am convinced
that as parents and caregivers,
we are missing out on a great opportunity
to raise kids who are resilient
and can take hold of their future,
kids who can step outside
of their comfort zone
and do amazing things.
Now, these are skills that are necessary
not only for them to lead fulfilling lives
and live out their potential,
but those are skills
that are also necessary
for our changing world.
So back to my original question.
How do we raise self-reliant
kids who have initiative,
are resilient and can be problem solvers?
I believe we do that by raising kids
who can think and act entrepreneurially.
Kids who have the opportunity
or have the skill set
to view the world
from an entrepreneurial mindset.
So let me tell you
how I came to this conclusion.
So for more than 20 years,
my work was centered around supporting
adult entrepreneurs.
Providing them with training
and technical assistance
and resources to help them start
and grow their businesses.
And something I would observe.
We'd have two individuals come
into our office seeking assistance.
And on the surface,
it appeared that those individuals
were at the same level
in terms of resources, capabilities,
skills and business acumen.
But what we would find
is that one individual
would take that information
and go with it,
and then the other individual
would just seem to have trouble
really getting traction and getting going.
And what I realized
was that it had nothing to do
with skill or capability.
What it came down to
was the mindset of that individual.
And observing this got me thinking:
How might I raise my children
such that they can view the world
like an entrepreneur?
That they would have
the courage to step out
and to change the world
with an entrepreneurial lens.
So that set us out,
my husband and I,
on a 15-year journey
to raise entrepreneurial kids.
And we really saw this come together
when my eldest son, Silas,
was nine years old.
We had been living here in Maryland
for about two years,
and my husband was planning
to travel back to Colorado
to visit his mother.
And so Silas asked me, he said, "Hey, mom,
can me and my brothers also go
with Dad to visit grandma?"
And I said, "Well, you know, Silas,
four airline tickets
were not in the budget,
but you can go
if you can buy your own ticket."
So he paused for a moment, and he said,
"OK, well, how much are airline tickets?"
And I said, "About 300 dollars."
And so his next question, I have to say,
it literally blew my mind.
So he said, "OK.
Can I find free stuff on Craigslist
and then resell it?"
Yeah, I was like, "Yeah, you can."
And so then, over the course
of that summer,
that's exactly what he did.
You know, he would get online
and research Craigslist.
My husband would take him
to go pick up those things,
and then I would help him take pictures
and post them online.
But then he also did some other things
that summer, he hustled.
So he baked and sold cookies.
And then he also washed cars.
And throughout that entire process,
my husband and I, we guided him along.
We were there to coach and encourage him,
but we allowed him to take the lead.
When it was time for him
to make his sales pitch,
you know, we coached him
on how to make the pitch,
but when it was time
to knock on the doors,
he stood forward, and we stepped back.
And that summer he raised the money.
He earned the money
to purchase his airline ticket.
And he made a little bit more.
And he bought me a gift.
But, you know, I'm like,
I don't know really
who he was thinking about
when he bought that gift.
If it was, like, me or him, I don't know.
(Laughter)
But think about the confidence
that this put in him at nine years old.
That he can have a big goal,
and that he could persevere
to achieve that goal.
Amazing.
But when I share that story
with other parents,
many of them shake their head
and say, "You know what?
My kid could never do that
because my kids don't have
the entrepreneurial gene."
Well, being entrepreneurial
is not genetic.
It is a set of behaviors
that can be learned
when given the opportunity.
Entrepreneurs are not born.
The skills and the experiences
that cause a person to be entrepreneurial
can be taught, and they can be nurtured.
Now, raising entrepreneurial kids
is more than just teaching them
how to start a business
so they can earn money.
Raising entrepreneurial kids
is really about preparing kids for life.
Equipping them with everything
that they need, with the confidence,
with the ability to speak up,
to persevere, to have tenacity,
to bounce back from fear and rejection.
Those are the things that are required
in our world to live to one's potential.
So in order for me to learn
as much as I could
about raising entrepreneurial kids,
I interviewed dozens of parents and kids
to find out what they were doing.
And so I want to share
with you what I learned,
and I want to share with you
five strategies
that I'm actually doing with my children
and that honestly,
I think every parent
should be doing with their children
to disrupt our conventional
way of parenting.
So, number one,
don't give them an allowance.
(Applause)
That's what I'm talking about, too, yes.
Don't give them an allowance.
Instead, challenge them
to start a business
to earn their spending money.
So this is my boys,
and this is one of the ways
that they've earned money,
their own spending money,
is they make bracelets.
And there is no better lesson
around the value of a dollar
than when you have to work hard
to earn each one of them.
And through this process,
our kids will learn confidence,
financial literacy,
public speaking, how to convince people,
all skills that are valuable
for the world that we live in.
So don't give them an allowance.
The next thing is
make them pay for their wants.
You know, key to entrepreneurship
is about personal
responsibility and ownership.
And it is amazing how,
when you put the responsibility
on someone else
to buy that thing that they said
they really wanted,
kind of shifts a little bit, right?
It really, really does.
It's no different with the kids.
And so we actually started this
quite early with our children.
So when Silas was about four years old,
I created “daddy dollars.”
(Laughter)
And the boys would earn daddy dollars
for doing things such as chores,
for exhibiting positive behavior
and for also reading books.
And Silas actually
purchased his first bike
from using daddy dollars.
He had to earn 250 daddy dollars,
and that allowed him
to purchase his first bike.
Now, yeah, you know,
these are not real dollars.
But to Silas, that experience
of working hard to earn that money
and to buy that bike
was a very real experience for him.
Also, in 2019, our family decided
to take a trip to Tanzania.
And so, you know, the boys
were really excited about it.
And I said, "Now, if you want
to go to Tanzania --
your dad and I are going --
but if you want to go to Tanzania,
you know what you got to do?"
What do you think I told them?
They're going to have to buy
their own airline ticket, yes.
Now, the tickets to Tanzania
were not cheap.
They were 900 dollars apiece.
Yeah.
But check this out.
This is what I just loved,
was when I told the boys
that they were going
to have to buy their own ticket,
Silas, remembering back
to what he had done
when he was about nine years old,
he said to his brothers,
"That's easy, don't worry about it.
I'll show you how to do it."
(Laughter)
Yes.
And sure enough,
they worked hard over several months,
and they did just that.
They were able to earn enough money
by selling their bracelets
that I showed you earlier,
and they all were able to go
with their parents to Tanzania.
So I would encourage you
to make your kids pay
for the things that they say they want.
The next is to reduce their prosperity.
Now let's admit it,
kids today have a lot of stuff, right?
And when you think about it,
I understand this need
and this desire as parents
to want to give our kids
experiences and things
that maybe we did not have
when we were children.
But when we choose a parenting style
of overindulging our children
by providing them with too much,
too soon, for too long,
with no effort on their part,
what we do is actually raise young people
who are self-centered and entitled.
And so when we, instead ...
In the [1800s],
it's interesting because Frederick
Douglass made a statement
that I thought was profound
even in the [1800s],
because we're dealing with it today.
And he said,
"If you wish to make your son helpless,
you need not cripple him
with a bullet or a bludgeon,
but simply place him
beyond the reach of necessity
and surround him with luxury and ease."
Still true today.
Steve Jobs in a graduation speech,
told the graduates to stay hungry.
And what we love about
entrepreneurs is their hustle.
And oftentimes that hustle is rooted
in a hunger for something.
But if our kids never want for anything,
what's going to motivate them
to take action?
So I encourage you to reduce
your kids' prosperity.
Next is to let them be delight-directed.
Entrepreneurs are lifelong learners.
They learn to do, not simply to know.
And when we encourage our children
to seek out learning
for the things that they
are most interested in,
they become learners
who seek to learn to do
because they're teaching themselves
as opposed to just simply
pouring in information,
which is sometimes what we get
in our education system.
And so this is my my son Isaiah.
His delight is drawing.
And so he spends hours drawing,
and he seeks out classes
[that] teach him how to draw.
And he was recently awarded
an award by the Smithsonian Museum
of African Art for creating --
(Applause)
this superhero,
from looking at a piece
of art in the museum.
And he designed this.
But now Isaiah is designing
logos for people.
Yeah, yeah, I love it.
So give them room and space
to follow their delights.
And then lastly,
let them solve their own problems.
Entrepreneurs are problem solvers,
and as parents it is our natural instinct
to want to step in and help our kids
solve their problems.
But when we do that all of the time,
we kind of squelch
the potential that they have
to discover new things about themselves
new capabilities that they might have.
It squelches their ability to go out
and find the answers for themselves.
So I want you to think
about those five things
as you begin to raise up young people.
And yeah, you know what?
It's very likely that my boys
may not choose business ownership
when they grow up.
And that’s OK.
Because whether a child chooses
to build a company
or become an employee,
it doesn't matter,
because every kid needs to learn
how to think like an entrepreneur.
And the sooner we do this as parents,
create an environment at home
where they have the opportunity
and multiple occasions
to challenge their beliefs
about what's possible within them,
to step outside of their comfort zone,
to take risks,
to learn from failure,
to bounce back from rejection,
then the sooner we'll put them on the path
of living out their potential
to lead very fulfilling
and successful lives.
Thank you.
(Applause)